Jody starts off this hour in Minnesota
hi Jody welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
I gave thanks for taking my call sure I
am calling because my husband and I are
working on baby step to great and we
recently started fostering my niece and
nephew and we will be watching them for
an indefinite amount of time so we will
be receiving money from the county for
fostering them and so what our original
plan was to put that money into a
separate account to use just for those
two kids and just to meet their needs
and anything that they need and then
anything beyond that we were just going
to kind of hold it in that account and
that they did end up going back to their
mom we were going to invest that money
for them and give it to them like when
they graduate high school that sort of
thing but where then it occurred to us
would should be actually be using that
money to pay off our debt instead yes I
guess we're just not sure the right
thing to be doing with that money yeah
what you were attempting to do was Noble
I mean the whole thing you're doing is
unbelievably Noble you're taking care of
these kids thank you but you were trying
to do it you're trying to something that
felt right with the money because
getting money to take care of family
member
kids feels a little icky to you and
you're trying to go well I want to push
it over there towards them because I
don't feel like I should be doing that
there's a little bit of that under the
surface here and that's kind of a normal
awkward feeling but here's the thing you
are going to write whatever checks are
necessary while those children are there
to take care of them aren't you
yeah okay so it's just coming out of one
pocket or the other this is you know you
can't set the money aside to take care
of them you're taking care of them it's
all in one bracket you know you're gonna
care for them and so and as far as their
future goes the other things the
way for you to help them big time in
their future if you want to do that if
they go back to their parents or
whatever with the excess money you're
talking about is for you to get out of
debt and you to have an emergency fund
and you to build wealth and then if
you've got a pile of wealth over here
and you look over and have a niece and
nephew you can just write a check sure
you know I talked to a guy the other day
that's a friend of mine he's a
multimillionaire
and he was so excited he had run a
spreadsheet and he said did you know
what a million dollars he'll do it I
wanna know what 1 million dollars do and
he said I can put a million dollars in a
mutual fund and the income off of that
mutual fund will pay for all of my
nieces and nephews to go to college wow
that's pretty cool yeah that's pretty
cool and that's just a million dollars
you know and so you're gonna be
millionaires you're on your way you're
doing this stuff we're teaching you're
gonna get out of debt you're gonna be
millionaires and by the time these kids
are how old 7 and 14 okay and so you
know ten years from now what mile not
quite seven years from now you're going
to want them in school probably but the
you know you're gonna be in a much
better position by the time they get to
college than you are today to do
something for them and part of that as a
result of just directing this money to
cleaning up your mess because that's the
shortest path to you being wealth which
wealthy which is the shortest path to
you helping them over all right so what
do you think the probability is you what
do you think the probability is you end
up adopting them I am Not sure at this
point their mom's still going through
treatment and things and so I don't know
I really honestly don't know it kind of
feels like a 50/50 shot at this point
well [ __ ] dick Tommy okay yeah you're
you're probably got these kids I hope
she makes it but you probably got these
kids right yeah I'm so glad you're there
I mean what a great thing and you can do
it you can do it what's your household
income we are right around 80,000 right
now yeah so we just moved and my husband
is graduated college and just started
I'm dry ball like in the last couple
weeks going through a lot of changes I'm
sure a lot of stress and this is his
family my family your family okay how
old are you two 38 and 39 okay cool and
you have kids of your own yes we have a
one in the three year old
wow what a houseful okay okay well
here's the other good news if that
occurs if you end up adopting them out
of foster eventually there's no cost for
college the state will pay for the
college oh I guess they didn't realize
that no adopting out of foster care is a
not only an inexpensive thing to do if
for people that want to do an adoption
is a zero to 2500 on average most of
time zero cost to adopt but also then
the state jumps in and does all kinds of
stuff in including paying for their
college so perfect you can verify that
in Minnesota but in all the states that
I'm aware of they do it so and it's just
it's a very very cool thing that you're
you're you've been able to do here I
hope for the sake of your family member
your sister that that she turns it
around and it turns out okay but meth is
just um it's just tough yeah that's a
that's a heroin and meth or two of the
toughest ones recidivism rate wise
percentage-wise but I mean God can do
anything and Pete the human spirit is
powerful and I hope she turns it around
right yeah me too I actually do have one
more question about it
speaking of God should we be tithing on
this money it's up to you I don't care
okay by the way God doesn't either he's
not sitting up there he's not setting up
their little chicken scratch going one
two three four cross five right he's
just not doing that it's not like
performance um you know you're taking
care of orphans which is a biblical
mandate and in effect for at least
temporarily their orphans right right
and so the money you're receiving to
take care of those kids is you you know
you can't outgive God so if you want
tithe on it fine but if you don't tithe
on it I can probably make you a real
good buy
study on why you don't need to but I
don't worry about all that stuff it's
just I always have giving way at the top
of my list and it never it never
disappoints me all right you're by the
way you're giving your whole freaking
home is open to a 14 year old 14 year
old hmm yeah that's that's giving right
there
hey you're incredible you're heroes way
to go very well done